monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les résultats de la
plateforme parcoursup sont désolants le
ministère a beau indiqué que seul 160
lycéens n'ont pas trouvé de place ce
sont en fait plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de bacheliers qui n'ont plus
accéder à l'enseignement supérieur cette
année
parcoursup est un instrument de gestion
de la pénurie au sein de l'enseignement
supérieur depuis 2008 le budget par
étudiant ne cesse de baisser et le taux
d'encadrement de régresser entre 2012 et
2017 seul 19 universités sur 68 ont vu
la part des enseignants titulaires
augmentaient et seulement 12 d'entre
elles leur taux d'encadrement
s'améliorer timidement cela a de lourdes
conséquences pour toute la société ainsi
alors que nous manquons de médecins dans
de plus en plus de nos territoires alors
qu'il y a pourtant une véritable
influence des candidatures pour les
études de santé sur parcoursup puisque
avec les études enfin avec les instituts
en soins infirmiers se sont celles qui
sont les plus demandées les capacités
d'accueil dans nos universités empêchent
non seulement des jeunes d'épouser des
carrières auxquelles ils aspirent mais
également de lutter efficacement contre
la désertification médicale et la
saturation de notre système public
d'enseignement supérieur pousse de plus
en plus d'élèves à se tourner vers des
formations privées 25% des étudiants du
supérieur ils sont inscrits et rien que
pour l'année 2021-2022 le marché privé
de l'Enseignement supérieur a progressé
de 10% quand le périmètre de
l'université ne le faisait que de 0,4%